take it easy because it's time for my
ultimate slow cooking
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy it's also an incredible way to
transform meat into mouth-wateringly
melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks to
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity slice
alongside the bone straight down you can
see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start coloring that in
[Music]
it's really important to give the beef
short rib a really nice sear
if you didn't brown the meat off
it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce
stir in a heaped teaspoon of tomato
puree
i'm just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it cooking out but smell a
puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs
red wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish it's a light cured pancetta
i want nice thick
lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not going to slice them
i'm just going to cut them in half
but look at the color on those lardons
now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp and have a
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall wait you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift and place
on the tray
beautiful to make a fantastic rich deep
sauce press the soft roasted garlic
through a sieve into the cooking juices
all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor
scrape
all of that
off the sieve
nice
then just start
sieving all that lovely braising liquor
wow
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on
your bacon
and your mushrooms
[Music]
useful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work really well so don't
be precious this is gutsy cooking at its
absolute best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cut and it's sort of tucked alongside
the rib they've been boned out the skin
has been taken off i'm going to roll
them stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
season
season them both sides inside and out
really important
it doesn't look like a real weighty
dense cut of meat but once it's
beautifully slow braised it's just like
melting lamb it's incredible i'm going
to season the breast with some dried
oregano
put a heat in there
some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
there's some amazing
salted anchovies in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb
so the balance of flavors
work beautifully
now pull it down
towards you and roll that nice and
tightly
that's what i'm looking for
string
i just need to tie them
three times one at each end and one in
the middle i fell in love with this dish
years ago when i first started working
in paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
get that oil nice and hot
lamb in
really important to get some nice color
on there
whilst they're browning
slice the onion
the lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours
so don't slice the onions too thinly
otherwise they'll burn
garlic and leave whole
got a color on them look at that
beautiful
take them out
onions in and garlic straight in
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans
why
all the goodness is in that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
oregano
nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there i'm gonna
do the onions what i did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding the bottom of the pan
they get nice and crispy
next my black olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
delays in the pan as well
i rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavour in there is just
extraordinary
now
where that tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
[Music]
lid on
into the oven
170
two
two and a half hours and forget about it
[Music]
whoa
beautiful
all that has reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb has kept its
color look at that it's braised
beautifully
very carefully
get your little bits there
slice
off pull off the little bits of string
this is why i get really excited the
secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
i can smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there that that is a
very cheap
cut of meat i'm salivating
i love this i mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
an amazing
rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
sit it on
it looks incredible
and that for me
is why chefs get so excited with cheap
cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish fit to grace any
table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
[Music]
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife
bring the pork belly towards you so
you're over it and you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife take your time
turn it
180.
this time what we're doing is just sort
of cutting these nice little sort of
diamonds but as that starts roasting on
top it starts getting nice and crispy
take
your handfuls of salt and just sort of
rub it in
bend it over and in all those cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
fennel in
i like the
nice strong
aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds delicious
star anise
in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear
the top of that fat that locks in all
that amazing flavor then i'm going to
flip it over and get it nice and crispy
and then i want fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now
some white wine
a minute that white wine hits that pan
you can smell that light
fragrance from the fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time
that the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there will be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and braises at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast the pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock
has evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavor packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat
take a couple of slices of bread it's
like a perfect sponge because you just
lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me stick that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife
you can hear that
that
is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy
belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
you